wir haben eine eilmeldung für sie und
die betrifft das vielleicht wichtigste
in dieser corona krise das einzige
mittel was wirklich hilft nämlich das
impfen
bei uns ist wieder reif schuler unser
parlament chef und wir haben etwas
vorliegen nämlich ein vertrauliches
dokument aus dem gesundheitsministerium
und da sehen wir wie viele impfungen und
impfdosen denn nun in den nächsten
monaten und quartalen tatsächlich nach
deutschland geliefert werden sollen
ralf vielleicht kannst du uns einmal
helfen einzuschätzen einzuordnen wird
das reichen woran hapert's eigentlich
und wann wird endlich besser wir sehen
dass der zufluss erst sehr langsam
zunimmt und das große problem besteht
eben darin dass wir bislang viel zu
wenig in die breite geimpft haben wir
haben die risikogruppen immunisiert aber
wir haben es nicht geschafft wirklich
diejenigen die zu den multiplikatoren
gehören in der öffentlichkeit
flächendeckend zu impfen und dann müssen
auch die beschlüsse nichts die wir
bisher gefasst haben
das im april auf hausärzte auszuweiten
so lange der impfstoff so langsam zu
läuft reicht es einfach vorn und hinten
nicht